[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 première
semaine d'exploitation pour le film Beur
sur la ville de Jamel Bensalah à
l'affiche ber Steve Tran ou encore Isa
dumbia formé à l'école Déclic Théâtre
att trrape le comédien est en plateau
pour 1 heure pour revenir sur ses débuts
sur grand écran bien sûr mais aussi sur
son parcours et aussi maître en lumière
sa ville trappe et ses principaux
acteurs et bonsoir Issa dbia salut
wilfri moi je te dis salut hein on se
connais depuis des années wilfreded les
gens vont tous savoir on va se tutoyer
pendant cette é moi je te tue toi il y a
pas il y a pas d'autre possib invité
d'honneur de cette émission pour 1 heure
d'autres invités vont nous rejoindre au
fur à mesure on va commencer par parler
de votre de ton premier film allez de
ton premier film Beur sur la ville sorti
mercredi dernier 346 salles 346 copies
c'était une sortie importante il y a eu
beaucoup de promotions autour de ce film
aujourd'hui
soulagé soulager oui parce que ouais
c'est un premier film où où ma carrière
commence pas par un un petit un petit
rôle mais vraiment un rôle important
dans un film de Jamel Bensalah qui a
déjà révélé Jamel Debou à l'époque donc
aussi un trapiste et prendre prendre la
relève c'est c'est c'est une nouvelle
tâche pour moi donc du coup je me suis
dit bah il faut y aller à fond et j'ai
rempli mon rôle j'espère et les
spectateurs pour l'instant nous font de
très bons retours
41287 spectateurs pour le premer jour
d'exploitation 3e place derrière Z
artiste avec Jean du jardin il y avait
de la concurrence en face ou encore un
monstre à Paris dessin animé europac
corp avec Matthieu Chedy et Vanessa
Paradis pour les voix ils font 80000
entrées sur le premier jour mais il y
avait deux fois plus de copies pour la
comparaison c'est un peu difficile vous
êtes en tout cas satisfait de l'accueil
du public les retours sont bons à vous
ah oui oui les retours sont sont plus
que bons même déjà les gens avaient une
certaine attente parce que j'avais créé
en fait un un facebook avec le
personnage du film qui s'appelle Mamadou
sayidou Koulibali où en fait j'avais pas
dit pour l'instant que c'était un
personnage qui était dans le film donc
je faisais des petits sketchs de 2
minutes sur Internet qui ont fait un
buzz et je pensais pas que ça allait
faire autant de bruit et au fur et à
mesure que ça avançait de qu'on se
rapprochait de la la date de sortie j'ai
annoncé que j'étais dans un film et les
gens ont tout de suite compris et
beaucoup de gens sont partis voir le
film et ont été agréablement surpris
beaucoup de projections en
avant-première même tout au long de
l'été il y a eu un tour de France qui
était organisé alors Beur sur la ville
c'est l'histoire de l'agent Belkassem
interprété par bouer il a tout raté dans
sa vie mais la discrimination positive
lui permet d'obtenir une affaire ante à
résoudre et puis comme officier Mamadou
Saidou Koulibali et Henri tong et hen
tong ou Koulibali un S papier hein qui
décidé de se cacher dans la police ça on
l'avait pas fait encore ouais voilà
c'est le premier sans papier qui a eu
l'idée d'aller se cacher dans la police
parce que c'est le seul endroit où on
peut pas contrôler donc du coup moi
quand Jamel benensam propose ça je me
dis le décalage est tellement énorme que
je je je prends tout de suite et en même
temps je pouvais pas refuser de faire un
rôle au cinéma avec Jamel benens Salah
qui a signé ne sa mère not ne sa mère
qui a fait le ciel les oiseaux et ta
mère le Raed Big City il était une fois
dans le wed il a fait des des films qu'
qu' on fait des bonnes entrées et qu' on
eu un gros succès donc je pouvais pas
refuser et ce film je tiens à dédicacer
ce film à auarcy parce que c'est grâce à
lui que j'ai j'ai eu ce ce rôle c'est
lui au départ qui devait faire le film
c'est ce que j'ai lu il il devait il
devait pas forcément faire le film il en
parlait avec Jamel ils ont parlé du
projet avec Jamel et il lui a dit est-ce
que tu connais un un jeune une garçon
black qui pourrait
répondre au aux demandes que j'ai par
rapport à ce personnage là et omarcy lui
a dit bouge pas j'en ai un pour toi et
il a parlé de moi est-ce que vous avez
travaillé avec Omar ben omomar c'est un
habitant de trappe donc déjà la base il
il me connaissait depuis que j'étais
tout petit j'avais de la moustache avant
lui et il me vannait il me disait il me
disait que j'avais pas j'avais pas mon
âge quand je lu disais que j'avais 17
ans il me disait non non tu en as 30
arrête de mentir donc du coup euh voilà
j'ai fait l'école avec sa avec sa sœur
une amie à moi et et voilà donc on se
connaissait depuis très très longtemps
pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore vu Beur
sur la ville de Jamel bensala avec Isa
dumbia et la bandeannonce justement on
continue en parler après pendant une
heure avec Issa
dumbia pas un noir pas un arabe à
félicité c'était la honte vous allez me
mettre de la couleur dans cette
promotion enfilez-moi de la couleur du
symbole j'élève au Grad de lieutenant de
police
khalidid il ressemble à rien ce bidon là
on dirait c'est ton
pèrerek vous êtes bien sûr que c'était
le plus nul il a toujours tout raté BC s
de la route et même sans
BCG profitez-en pour le charger de cette
histoire du tueur du vendredi police
nationale c'est une enquête de voisinage
n'ayez pas peur c'est à propos de votre
voisine
décapité non mais écoutez en travail là
je vous rappelle que vous êtes là pour
faire jolie il y a au moins 10000
€ 10000 € ça fait 2000 € chacun on est
refa vous avez pas le permis B non non
mais vous vous servez vraiment à rien
quoi c'est qui cet abrutil là c'est
compliqué
police comme tu m'as dit qu'il mangeait
pas de porc j'ai fait du sanglier mais
maman
mais oh coquin toi oh Alice vous avez
droit au crevette oh oui oui oui on peut
même manger des boules messieurs je vous
demanderai la plus grande vigilance pas
de bavure salut les
bon problème et Arab toujours les
problèmes avec
[Applaudissements]
vousgage
su la
police vous êtes la honte de la police
ça chingue ici ouais che ta mère pour sa
chlingue elle est belle notre police
hein beurre sur la ville à l'affiche
depuis mercredi dernier avec un trio
Issa dumbia boouer et Steve Stran il a
aussi au casting beaucoup d'acteurs
connus reconnus comme Sandrine kiberlin
Josian balasco Gérard junio des clin
d'œil aussi on l'a pas vu dans la
bandeannonce mais il y a Jean-Claude Van
Dam aussi au casting alors comment se
passe la cohabitation sur un tournage
avec Josian balasque au C kimberlin et
puis et puis pourquoi pas aussi
Jean-Claude Vanam franchement alors le
jour où j'ai tourné avec Jean-Claude
Vanam c'était tellement tellement drôle
et tellement un rêve d'enfant c'était
drôle de pas parce que pas parce que ce
qu'on connaît de lui à la télé avec ses
eware et tout ça non du tout c'est
vraiment un homme très très timide
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire et
quand il est arrivé sur le plateau nous
ça faisait déjà plus d'un mois qu'on
tournait donc il est arrivé il a senti
tout de suite qu'il y avait une ambiance
sur le plateau il s'est dit ou où
j'arrive et on a détendu et après il a
déconné avec nous toute la journée de
tournage qu'on a passé avec lui et ça
s'est super bien passé entre les prises
je lui demandais tape-moi comme dans tes
films s'il te plaît Jean-Claude parce
que je peux j'aurais pas l'autre une
autre occasion peut-être de de rejouer
avec toi et il me faisait des petites
prises comme dans les films c'était très
drôle il y a beaucoup de comédiens qui
ont fait des écoles on va dire
classiques d'apprentissage de de la
comédie le parcours d'adumbia c'est
plutôt l'improvisation est-ce qu'on peut
improviser sur un film comme ça est-ce
que Jamel a laissé la place à l'impro ou
au cont très bonne question parce que
quand on a eu les lectures du du
scénario quand on a fait des lectures
avec les autres comédiens donc les
lectures ça se passe comment c'est on a
le scénario et il y a le réalisateur qui
veut qu'on essaie de jouer un petit peu
les
situations et ben moi je lui ai demandé
dès le départ si j'avais le droit
d'improviser puisque je venais du monde
de l'impro il m'a dit oui pourquoi pas
on ver donc déjà à la base le personnage
il avait pas d'accent c'est il voulait
tout simplement un 100 papier et j'ai
rajouté l'accent après il y a des
situations qui sont dans le film qu'on a
rajouté pendant les lectures parce que
je lui ai proposé des vannes en plus et
il y avait la place et après sur le
plateau comme parfois il y a des choses
qu'on écrit qui ne passent pas
forcément à l'écran et ben du coup on
les joue différemment et j'ai eu aussi
d'autres proposition à ce moment-là en
terme de jeu Issa dambur sur la ville
petit extrait de sa
prestation ah Salut Bonjour bonjour je
viens vous poser des questions par
rapport au tu du vendredi ça vous
dérange pas non non viens viens rentre
viens tranquille d' je crois que tu vas
être le goffé comme ça toute seule comme
une grosse ah non madame faut pas
par je t' dit que tuun grosse mais
c'est ta mère la grosse
[Applaudissements]
et pourquoi l'accent
pouroac
alors pareil quand ENF quand je commence
quand j'ai commencé le théâtre tout de
suite quand on arrive réfugier derrière
personnage où on sent à l'aise et ben du
coup on l'utilise souvent donc depuis
que je suis petit depuis l'âge de 11 ans
quand je fais des personnages c'est plus
facile pour moi de m'exprimer que de que
de jouer Issa Issa même donc du coup
quand j'ai j'ai commencé à jouer aux
premières lecture avec ma voix je me
suis dit il y a un truc qui me gêne et
je lui ai proposé l'accent ça tout de
suite ça a donné une autre dimension et
ça a renforcé le côté qu'il était sans
papier et pour moi c'est vraiment une
protection et cet accent les internautes
l'ont découvert bientôt on en a parlé
tout à l'heure on va voir une de ces
petites séquences vidéos qui ont fait
buzzer le le web de ces vidéos de
Mamadou Saidou Koulibali yes bonne nuour
c'est Mamadou Saidou Koulibali bon je
suis rentré du travail là bon j'ai un
peu speed il faut que j'aille me douser
toi aussi bon j'avais des questions pour
poser à vous là les de de Facebook parce
que je comprends pas moi je suis en
train de marcher dans la ru avec le
collègues ont fait des des contrôles qu
tranquillement quoi il y a des gens ils
passent à côté ils font des poulets
poulet poulet est-ce que moi j'ai des
têtes de poulet est-ce que tu m'as vu
déjà faire des cotcot non vraiment vous
êtes c'est pas
assumer alias mamadouou Koulibali
pendant que la séquence continue à
défiler on peut peut-être quand même
préciser que il y a beaucoup
d'internautes qui ont cru que c'était
vrai au début Mme après par que au début
en fait la première vidéo que j'ai posté
c'était euh c'était un un homme qui
cherchait des amis tout simplement et
voilà parce que sur Facebook c'est c'est
ce que les gens cherche en fait c'est
d'avoir des amis et moi j'ai fait une
vidéo en demandant des amis et en une
nuit j'ai j'ai j'ai vraiment halluciné
j'ai eu plus de plus de 2000 demandes et
le lendemain j'avais déjà un compte
complet donc en 2 jours j'avais 5000
amis donc j'ai dû rouvrir une deuxième
un deuxème compte puis un troè et après
tellement j'avais des des amis j'ai
ouvert une page et aujourd'hui sur la
page il y a plus de je sais pas 180000
personnes qui sont qui sont amis avec
Mamadou Saidou Koulibali donc quelque
part c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est drôle
c'est plaisant mais en même temps j'ai
j'ai joué à un jeu un peu dangereux puis
que on aurait pu
gâcher surprise sur film et et que les
gens soient saoulés de voir le
personnage et d'aller au cinéma mais du
coup les gens ont apprécié ils sont
partis voir le film dans un instant nous
allons recevoir sur le plateau une
partie de l'écpe de de l'équipe de
Déclic Théâtre compagnie sur trap où
vous avez débuté vous êtes toujours
derri je refuse de parler de Déclic
Théâtre qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est une
surprise pour l'instant bon pas
tellement une surprise et auparavant une
petite parenthèse parce qu'il y a un
thème très sérieux qui est abordé dans
le film c'est la discrimination positive
nous sommes allés demander aux
cinquantinois ce qu'il pensaient est-ce
qu'il croyait en la discrimination
positive alors qu'est-ce que vous
appelez la discrimination positive mais
il faut engager tout le monde RRE les
choses obligatoires B à mon avis c'est
un retour un retour en arrière sur notre
épanouissement notre développement et
même je pense au niveau de notre prise
de responsabilité bah je crois que en ce
moment c'est pas tellement à l'ordre du
jour ni dans la vie civile ou municipale
ni dans les entreprises en tout cas dans
les entreprise où je travaillais parce
que je ne travailleais plus c'était pas
tellement ça c'est dans l'air du temps
mais pour l'instant c'est pas tellement
mis en application je pense je dois
avouer que je suis
pas pas très sensible à ça quoi la
discrimination c'est quelque chose
d'affreux hein que tout le monde est
tous les hommes sont égau et qu'il soit
noir blanc jaune hein on est toutes
pareil c'est des deux termes
antagonistes discrimination c'est plutôt
négatif donc je vois pas trop comment ça
peut être positif quoi quel regard vous
avez Isa sur cette discrimination
positive don il est question dans
filmber sur la ville mais sous le thème
de la comédie forcément comme je dis à
chaque fois moi euh la discrimination ça
ça ça me parle pas parce que j'ai grandi
en France et mes parents m'ont jamais
m'ont jamais dit tu as un noir traîne
avec des noirs et parle qu'avec des
noirs et fais que fais ta vie en noir
non et même quand je suis parti au
théâtre on m'a jamais appris à être un
black on m'a appris à être un comédien
donc c'est ce que je dis à chaque fois
moi j'apprends pas à être noir je sais
que je le suis et euh je suis euh je
suis à la je suis un humain comme tout
le monde et mais là par exemple dans
beurre sur la ville vous vous jouez euh
vous jouez un black avec un sans papier
avec un fort accent c'est un personnage
vous avez pas peur d'être enfermé dans
ce personnage personnage du tout non
pourquoi j'ai joué d'autres rôles juste
derrière avec euh euh des personnages
qui avaient pas forcément d'accent euh
et euh ça m'a ça m'a jamais bloqué non
le je pense qu'il y a c'est vrai qu'on
sent qu'il y a un frein dans le cinéma
français mais euh j'espère que les gens
ouvriront les yeux et et on peut
regarder aujourd'hui quand on voit moi
je j'adore voir des des affiches où je
vois om Omar si et François Cluset à à
l'affiche moi je me dis voilà il y a là
c'est c'est une affiche de d'aujourd'hui
puisque il y a des blacks qui qui sont
avec des blancs avec des jaunes avec des
Verts des bleus et voilà tout le monde
s'entend bien après chacun chacun fait
ce qu'il veut pour moi en tout cas je je
j'aime pas trop ce terme de
discrimination Isa dumbia vous restez
sur le plateau avec nous on va continuer
ce 78 encore pendant TR quarts d'heure
juste le temps de faire une pause pour
découvrir les principes aux titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi qui seront
développés dans le journal tout en image
de la rédaction à 20h30 et à 22h oui
bien sû en im c'est vrai les titres en
image tout de suite dans l'actualité de
ce mercredi 19 octobre le laboratoire
d'analyse médicale de manilamo pourrait
fermer chaque mois il reçoit personnes
la mairie se mobilise les inspecteurs du
permis de conduire sont en grève un
mouvement national et illimité nous
verrons les conséquences dans les
ivelines notamment pour ces candidats
qui ne pourront pas passer leur permis
cette semaine une exposition consacrée
aux adctologies se déroule jusqu'au 29
octobre à l'Hôtel de Ville de
guilloncour le fruit du travail mené
conjointement entre un photographe un
addictologue et de jeunes lycéens il
s'appelle isadumbia à l'affiche depuis
une semaine de beurre sur la ville comme
bien d'autres avant lui Issa a fréquenté
les bandes de Déclic Théâtre attrape une
école du talent qui a vu notamment
débuter Jamel
Debous